i don't know how much of our last
conversation you heard um
i'm sure you've been following lebron on
instagram and he talked about what
they're gonna say now
you know uh come up with some criteria
that nobody else in history has ever had
to uh to deal with
what do you think he's saying there
what's he getting at
well i wrote in the intro of this column
is like when you talk about lebron's
legacy it is filled with doubt every
step of the way the chosen one sports
illustrated cover
he was a guy who went to the finals at
22 won a scoring title at 23 and an mvp
at 24. okay check
the guy leaves cleveland everyone thinks
there's no way that guy can be beloved
by cleveland he wins at two titles in
miami finals mvps and then goes back to
cleveland and wins the title beloved by
cleveland again check wins the titles in
miami which a lot of people thought he
was a flawed superstar who couldn't win
the big one check and then he goes to
l.a and replenishes the stature of the
lakers check so every step of the way of
his career lebron james has quieted the
doubters and so i can totally get why
he's sitting here being like i wonder
what they're gonna make up now and
i think
you know what i get in this column and
what i'd love to hear you guys talk
about here is
i think it's wrong to think that lebron
should try to get to six titles as if
that's gonna change the conversation in
his favor because i think no matter what
he does and how unfair it is for lebron
james if he gets to six titles most
people are just gonna think six losses
in their head the 6-0 spotless record by
by michael jordan is unassailable in his
corner but for lebron to win the goat
debate
he's going to have to in my opinion
change the conversation like he always
has and to me that's getting all-time
scoring leader beating karim aldul
jabar's record he's 4 000 points away
and i think anthony davis is the perfect
running mate to get him to that next
step of his career and once he wins that
all-time scoring leader when it's not
even his best skill
i think the goat debate will be over
you know it's so interesting stro i mean
we talked about this yesterday of how of
how he is
he is totally fine with anthony davis
too when they talk when he talked about
from that press conference he said we're
not jealous of each other and we push
each other you can see that i mean
anthony davis was their leading scorer
he gives you 10 assists a game lebron
did highest assist total in his career
he's equipped to do exactly what you're
saying to play with another superstar
and be fine with it but my question for
you is
where do you think he goes
in the next four years in terms of his
play
championships
what's in store for lebron four years
from now
you could say that his body is going to
deteriorate somewhat but this dude just
led all postseason players in transition
buckets by amanda you can put jimmy
jimmy butler giannis
and russell westbrook transition baskets
this entire postseason combined and
lebron still has more so we're talking
about a guy who's almost he's
approaching 40 years old and no one can
still stop him like a freight train in
the open court and so when people say
like what's this decline going to look
like for lebron
i still think that lebron james has a
couple more years of being an
unstoppable force in transition and
the pick and roll with anthony davis is
going to become that much more
impossible to guard now that anthony has
seen he can win a title at the five when
he becomes a center
defensive player of the year pick and
roll partner with three shooters around
them good luck
and so in the open court and in the half
court i think lebron james is going to
have a field day even as he turns 36 37
38 i think he's going to win this
scoring title um and especially with
brawny his son on the horizon i just
think at the end of the day people are
going to see this guy aging into 40 and
he's not going to fall off like we see
typically because he takes so such good
care of his body i think he's going to
be more or less the same player we saw
last year
that's my question for you
yeah you talk about taking care of his
body
uh we were talking the other day i said
to mike you know you very rarely saw
michael jordan
just kind of sucking for air he was just
all his motor was very high same thing
with
with lebron james any stories any
legendary stories i know uh how workouts
are important to a pat riley
organization some of his stories are
legendary of like how he would find guys
for being a pound overweight but
you hear the workout stories of lebron
and some of his feats in the gym
yeah lebron like he he doesn't need to
do the the off-season workouts to just
walk in and run anybody out everybody
out of the gym there's one time where in
the in the finals he was doing a
a practice
where he was beating ray allen and mario
chalmers in a three-point contest around
the world
and i remember watching this and being
like this guy
is going to lead the nba and assist
potentially he's going to make you know
lead everyone in the paint percent field
goal percentage and yet we still haven't
seen him at his peak in terms of
shooting and this guy does have that
lever where he can pull and be like i'm
just gonna hit six three you saw that at
the end of the finals where he was like
i'm gonna hit six threes and
in terms of fitness
i mean i remember brian winhurst who had
covered lebron for you know a half
decade before i got down to miami and he
said when you see lebron's ankles
they're the size of normal person's
thighs
and when you look at it in person it is
just jarring is just how big those legs
are
you can't put it into words like they're
tree trunks they're huge and so when you
talk about lebron james as a point guard
that dude in any other era is a center
like he's 280 pounds and six nine he's
bigger than ben wallace he's the same
size as dwight howard and so when we
talk about his abilities to age he's
just got such a strong base and he's
just he's a point guard like he's got so
many different skills
and you know i don't want to hear this
whole michael jordan you know against
the magic series like he wasn't in shape
i i hate that narrative like the guy
scored 48 points in that first game of
that postseason when he came back
against the hornets and he dropped 39 i
think in game five of that orlando magic
series which he lost so like this idea
that michael jordan wasn't in tip-top
shape and therefore we can discount that
i'm back season it's ludicrous we would
never give lebron the benefit of the
doubt there
let me go back to your original point i
mean i agree with you obviously that
anthony davis is going to extend his
career
um
in a multitude of ways
but
i was thinking when you were talking and
i just tell you what i said yesterday
about what lebron
may do in a laker uniform which is
important let me stress that again tom
laker uniform he could pass kareem in a
laker uniform
he'll probably pass magic and assist in
a laker uniform
and he will join a a a interesting
conversation whereas
laker greats are their own kind of nba
history top five you could do a top five
on mount rushmore with just laker
players that's a pretty good all-time
nba top five so there's something
emotional and that's where i would go
if if you still think lebron can win the
goat debate if there's a winning
uh the debate for lebron i don't think
it's empirical because he's already
passed jordan
on the all-time scoring list so he's
already got more points than jordan
and jordan people just say well yeah
jordan went to college for example you
know what i mean or he retired twice you
know what i mean so you know he's
already got more points than jordan more
assists there are people and i'm not one
of them who like to think that lebron is
so much better an all-around player than
michael jordan to begin with so i'm not
sure what i'm saying is i'm not sure
that for some
being the all-time scoring leader
is a mic drop moment for lebron james or
michael jordan i think it's got to be
something more emotional and it just
might be
running off with anthony davis to your
point as a sidekick three four five more
titles to where it's just like okay look
yeah he lost six but my goodness you
know he's got he's got seven or eight it
might have to be that kind of thing you
might have to really dominate the league
for another five years to win it in some
people's mind right so what you're
saying is there's gonna be have to be a
story in his favor uh legacy and
narrative that makes people yeah he's
got the numbers yeah
yes that's what i'm saying yeah he
already has more career win shares than
michael jordan he's already got more
points than michael jordan he's already
got more playoff wins than michael
jordan he's got more finals appearances
than michael jordan so what you're
saying is i agree is that if this isn't
going to come down to the numbers it's
going to come down to how i mean if
it or not the narrative right and so i
think
one thing we don't talk about enough is
lebron james he rides in the sunset with
his son on the lakers
i mean
we haven't seen that right like the the
whole story of lebron james changes if
he's right he's playing nba basketball
long enough that we saw him as a
teenager and to bring his own son was a
teenager like talk about the narrative
lebron being beloved by cleveland
think about that he imagine if i had
told you in 2010
when you saw what was happening in the
arena in cleveland the signs that they
were holding in cleveland which is the
ugliest that sports has ever been that
that same city would belove lebron would
love lebron again
never count him out
michael could you understand what i'm
saying michael like it's just because
this whole argument is emotional not
right now because if anybody if he
passed kareem then maybe that puts him
above kareem on the goat list
he's already passed jordan the whole
thing is emotional michael can't you
just see somebody 20 years from now yeah
but michael jordan they never played
with his son lebron played with his son
that's right but you know i guess people
will reach for anything in this
conversation
well but you know
and uh tom you just said something you
know talk about the emotional part of it
michael you said the same thing
what what is that for you what is that
emotional thing that you won't let go of
is it is it about is it a sports thing
is it a musical thing
because i'm just trying to understand
why it's so important to people
to protect for those who are who are
michael jordan people so to speak
why is it so important for them to
protect george
like jordan's going to be great
whether he already knows
whether lebron passes him or not he's
still great you know why is that so i
don't know i already i already know the
answer but go ahead tom you guys i'll
tell you that's after tom go ahead mike
tom well for me i was a huge red sox fan
growing up so you guys will appreciate
this i was at fenway park for game three
of the 2004 klcs i still have the ticket
stub in my pocket
and as a red sox fan being in fenway
park for the bottom of the barrel down
0-3 in a series against your hated
yankees rivals and then that team coming
back from down three went four straight
against the yankees and then winning the
world series which by the way everyone
forgets that the world series after that
the way right
that will never that feeling of what it
was like to be in fenway park and
feeling like this was done the whole the
whole insecurities of being a sports fan
is true and then to come back and roar
back and make everything right again
and be in that just euphoric state
that's what i think cleveland fans have
felt when lebron won 2016
and i just don't know if lebron has a
national
level of that where michael jordan's
uh follow through against utah i mean
you can't you can't script it any better
than that and so it's going to be hard
for lebron to top that
you know what's interesting too just
going back to like there's always
somebody doubting and i'm gonna answer
your question too for michael but before
i just popped in my head too even if you
go back to game five which feels like
you know it never happened but then the
game five that same old
right basketball play versus killer
instinct take the shot conversation was
kind of creeping up but then obviously
game six rendered a move point michael
you know why
you know why uh people won't let go of
uh stuff like michael jordan
real simple people like to be wrong
people don't like to be wrong they don't
like to change their mind and you know
who really doesn't like to be wrong
old people old people so the older you
get the more set in your ways you are
you ain't about to tell nobody who grew
up on michael jordan or before that
magic johnson that's somebody going to
come around and be better you ain't
telling them that it's you know it's
same with kobe there's a generation of
people that are like yo what about kobe
what about kobe kobe is the goat why are
you always talking about jordan because
they grew up on kobe and they're not
changing their minds people just will
not step back and say we live in a
society in general people time you know
this will not step back no matter how
many numbers you put in front of them
tom they will not step back and be like
you know what
you're right
you're right like hey i said you guys
like i saw what i saw never i don't care
what you said never did keep your little
never keep your little numbers keep your
little numbers exactly they will never
do that hey strobe before i let you go
man i got one more thing for you um
i want to talk about jimmy butler
because typically we don't remember who
finishes second
that's not somebody who i think will
forget that performance those two
masterpieces he put up in the finals
that iconic photo
of him being exhausted you want to talk
about somebody who was a worthy
adversary for the king sometimes you do
remember who finished second like those
are you see the numbers right there 26 8
and almost 10 assists a game
how will how will history look back at
this performance from jimmy butler and
also how do you view jimmy butler now
moving forward in terms of just your
overall hierarchy of nba stars or even
superstars
he reminds me of d wade before lebron
came to miami where he is the
institutional guy like he is the reason
why lebron went to miami and trusted
uh d wade and eric spoelstra and pat
riley because he's the incumbent right
for me i don't think jimmy butler gets
his full flowers
until giannis another kumpo comes to
miami and wins a title next to jimmy
butler just like lebron did with d-wade
like i think that is when jimmy butler's
true power will be understood because
that's the thing
jimmy butler was supposed to come in
here and in a couple years maybe get to
the finals another co-star he's already
there he's already legitimized and and
pacified the critics and so i feel like
jimmy butler i wrote a call about this
too is people didn't give him enough
credit because he didn't win deep into
the playoffs and eric's poster called an
anti-analytics guy the analytics have
loved jimmy butler and now people are
starting to see
he is super efficient gets to the free
throwing on that crazy and people in the
analytic community love
free throws they like three pointers but
they love free throws and so jimmy
butler the reputation that he's getting
right now man like the analytics and the
numbers community have been screaming
for years for him to get in a winning
situation he's there in miami
cool appreciate you man hey we
appreciate you bro
you